frühjahrsputz oder klappern mächtige
panzer rollen durch das gelände
tausende menschen die obersten gespannt
das geschehen
die dynamische panzer vorführung war nur
eines der highlights am tag der offenen
tür in der hessen kassel 1 als verband
aus juristischen bundesheeres wollen wir
natürlich der bevölkerung zeigen was wir
haben was wir können aber es ist
natürlich auch sie nur zweck der sache
zu zeigen was wir nicht haben und was
wir nicht können
es sollte sozusagen geben unternehmen
seinen von beiden seiten aber wir sind
natürlich der bevölkerung verpflichtet
und deshalb laden wir sie alle zwei
jahre einen tag mit uns zu verbringen
wir haben hier das einzige hanseaten im
österreichischen bundesheer diese
notiert wir haben die einzige zentrale
personalgewinnung abteilung des heeres
personalamtes hier und wir haben viele
einzigartige groß prüfstände die es hier
in österreich nur in der hessen kassel
es gibt nämlich für den kampfpanzer
leopard 2 4
das hat dafür sich dem leopard 2 4 ist
noch immer ein sehr gutes und das
möchten wir heute natürlich auch zeigen
dass wir noch immer einsatzbereit sind
aber um das so beibehalten würden wir
natürlich ein kleines update für unseren
kampf unterbrochen
derzeit sind in der hessen kaserne 500
soldatinnen soldaten und
zivilbedienstete sowie 100
grundwehrdiener stationiert blieben
sogar sich lehrlinge die in zehn
verschiedenen lehrberufen ausgebildet
werden
natürlich zeigen wir auch alle
karrieremöglichkeiten des bundesheeres
auf sei es als lehrling hz sowie
bedienstete oder durch ein soldat beim
in allen funktionen die wir haben wir
wollen und wir waren und die brille
flogen als erster wieder auf gestartet
dann an ein flugzeug und im panzer drin
das war cool als früher verlässlich und
vor interessant weil man von jeder
abteilung
das ist die schnellste war schon bei den
baum zu fahren die vorführung der
container denn was darauf kommen haben
das war ja vorstellen diesen riesen
geräte einfach dass die leute stürmen
die hessen kaserne wesen friedlicher
absicht und das ist natürlich für uns
eine große freude wenn die besten und
soldaten große anstrengungen unternommen
haben hier etwas schönes zu bieten
sie sorgen für die sicherheit
österreichs die soldatinnen und soldaten
des bundesheeres